and
[Music]
I'm going to say welcome to everyone as
you file in from the waiting room
and we'd love to know where you're
joining us from
a city state or country are you joining
us from
Florida
great welcome
and we're getting more people coming in
from the waiting room
we'll be starting as you can see in
under two minutes we've got uh Andy
Lewis here who is uh
entrepreneur
as his own consulting firm and is one of
the senior trainers with the simply run
program so
welcome everyone
uh you have folks from Texas Connecticut
looking for West Coast Illinois
before we haven't gotten this side of
the Mississippi yet
oh Texas is I'm sorry well I apologize
for that
usually better with geography
Columbia
welcome from South America that's
wonderful to see
Brazil
hello and bungia
you're in Portugal right now Andy yep no
I'm in Portugal
and I'm in the San Francisco Bay area in
California so
Atlanta Georgia
Canada
nice
perfect
so far up and down North and South
America this is great glad to have you
all here
we'll be starting
momentarily
all right
excuse me for looking over my shoulder
but
I have a second system set up to do the
presentation slides
and
welcome everyone my name is Stuart Creek
I'm with simply learn
with the triamney and I don't want to
talk or talk about uh we're here to talk
about the Caltech Center for technology
management education
cloud computing bootcamp program
how that can help you get your career
launched in the field of cloud computing
so it's great to see everybody joining
us from all around North and South
America
and a few ground rules for the webinar
please put your questions in the Q a box
that will help us keep track of them
uh the
chat we can't guarantee we'll be able to
find your question
there's a lot of messages going back and
forth
the Q a box will always keep them front
and center
this session is being recorded we will
send you a follow-up email with a link
to the recording and to the bonus offer
that we mentioned in the invitation
about
receiving a bonus offer for being here
at today's session
to request a proof of attendance for
this webinar once you are
leaded the webinar
let be taken into a post webinar survey
so put your name into the required field
there
you'll be able to receive that
emailed post webinar proof of attendance
so all that said let's get started
today we're going to be talking about
you I'm going to be asking you a few
questions about you meaning you in the
audience
a few poll questions
and
um
cloud computing careers I'll talk with
Andy about this
experience and how you might be able to
emulate his success what you'll need to
be equipped with to do that and how
Caltech ctme can help you with that
we'll share some of the learner outcomes
from the program and we'll go into
how to enroll and bonus offer that I
mentioned
said we'll get to your q a live toward
the end of the session so
we just do put your questions in the Q a
when they occur to you so
um
I'm going to start with this first poll
this first poll is
how much experience do you have we'd
like to get a feel for who's in the
audience
how long you've been in the industry or
are you still studying for your degree
leave this poll open for just about
another
five seconds
your answer is in hit the submit button
and I will close the poll in three
to one
okay
so Andy it's an interesting distribution
um we have about a third or so of our
audience who are still studying
um and then the rest are divided between
people who are new in industry and
people who are more seasoned in
Industries
gives you an idea of who we've got uh
here and we can talk about how this
program
can address each of their needs
and before I introduce Andy I just want
to make sure that you get the chance to
introduce simply learn where we call
ourselves the world's number one online
boot camp
specializing in digital skills for the
digital economy
helped over five million people upskill
for the digital economy over the last 13
years and it's been a long period of
digital transformation and especially
the last several years
very very rapid digital transformation
due to the pandemic so
having these digital skills is more
essential than ever and we're very proud
to be able to help people with that I'm
proud to be the delivery partner for
Caltech and we're also very proud to
have books like Andy working with us to
help you so Andy if you'd like to
introduce yourself and until folks about
your um your company your background and
qualifications absolutely well first off
uh welcome everybody to the webinar at
simpler my name is Andy Lewis I am uh
owner of try on the I.T services and one
of the activities that I perform is
professional training so I've been
associated with simple learn for several
years now and kind of spearheading uh
the Caltech course curriculum
I'm primarily the instructor for the AWS
courses in this curriculum as we'll talk
about later on I also do software
development and consultant as well
mostly in the Aerospace industry so I've
been doing this
development stuff from all the way back
to from 1999 where I started my career
with the Canadian space agency working
in the satellite operations and so I've
always been working in the Aerospace
industry and teaching at the same time
so I've been a kind of a full-time
instructor since 2008 and going in and
out of the industry and I think that's a
good thing for everybody because I'm
able to bring back the lessons learned
from you know what works and what
doesn't back in the classroom and and
vice versa so right now I am primarily
teaching AWS because that is something
that is very very much uh in demand for
the last couple years and I don't really
see an end in sight especially in the
near to midterm so this is also a very
good thing for you since you'll be able
to inherit that
great thank you so much for that and uh
reminder in the chat for folks to put
their questions in the Q a and that
we'll talk about the bonus toward the
end but right now we're going to talk
about careers in cloud computing and
kind of set the stage for that we talked
about oops
the the fact that cloud is the backbone
of the digital economy could we could we
have
could we have survived the pandemic and
the shifts to work from home and
non-contact uh
ordering and all of the other changes we
had to go through if we didn't have
Cloud Dandy
I think that we wouldn't have been able
to get there as quickly as we did I mean
so I can speak for a company that I was
working for uh particularly at the time
it was within a week they had us up and
uh running
um you know in the cloud now of course
there would have been Alternatives if
there was no Cloud but you know that
would have taken you know perhaps a
month or more to even get something
working and even then they would have
had to maintain the whole kind of
architecture and infrastructure and
behind the scenes so I would have been a
a huge headache it definitely wouldn't
have gone as smooth as as it did with uh
with the current situation yeah and and
cloud computing kind of evolved out of
Amazon's need to be able to handle you
know vast numbers of users over vast
distances and huge Geographic footprint
and um be able to scale up and scale
down their operations based on
seasonality and special events and that
type of thing so that's really kind of
where
um
the concepts of distributed computing
turned into Cloud isn't it yeah so right
now uh if we kind of think back to the
way things started every company has
some room blocked off uh where they have
a whole bunch of servers running right
and that's called an on-premise Data
Center and there's nothing odd about
that that's just the way things have
always been and in fact a lot of people
still have that a lot of companies still
go that route however uh
those are expensive and time consuming
to set up you got to have a whole team
to manage that
um and with that team comes a whole
bunch of other responsibilities like you
know the physical nature of the building
the rent the electricity the heating The
Ordering of the equipment the
installation the configuration it's a
big thing so the cloud kind of abstracts
all that away and says hey the world is
your oyster so to speak you know the
world is your data center pick a region
whether it be in South Africa Australia
Israel Virginia and deploy your
applications on our data centers as you
wish right in multiple areas if you wish
as well for a redundancy and fault
tolerance and so you can get up
and and deploy a business application
within a very short amount of time and
not have to invest in all that overhead
I just iterated through earlier
yeah and that that's really
powerful change
um now if you're
in your home thinking about starting up
a business whether it's content creation
or maybe an online store that type of
thing you have the ability to basically
find service providers and and turn that
on Within a matter of hours not minutes
and this is you know kind of the
background of what cloud has enabled
um the the software is a service Market
is
growing to huge proportions the platform
as a service Market is following and
spending on public Cloud as you can see
from you know the year before the
pandemic to
the year coming up
more than doubled so this kind of growth
as you said earlier you don't see that
stopping do you
no it's a it's actually being forecasted
to be even more and more uh in the in
the very near future so uh you you know
companies like Azure Microsoft right
they're investing huge amounts of money
even Google uh into more data centers
across the world uh and so there is no
you know slow down really uh companies
are you know maybe perhaps being a
little more uh reserved in their
spending right now but uh they're still
have the cloud on the map so lots of
companies today are thinking about more
of a hybrid architecture where yes they
do Leverage The Cloud but they'll also
leverage their on-premise data center so
that together is what's called a hybrid
architecture
this is a a small anecdote a number of
years ago I took my family on a vacation
to Oregon we went up to the Columbia
River and saw the Bonneville Dam which
was one of the first big hydroelectric
dams
and
it was interesting history it's in a
little town called The Dalles and a few
years after that I found out that Google
had chosen to build a data center in The
Dalles in the middle of almost nowhere
Oregon
but the reason was because the
Bonneville power Dam
produces reliable electrical energy and
has lots of water for cooling the data
center so it's amazing where where the
clouds uh physical tendrils have reached
um yeah they're kind of a hidden hidden
uh asset they don't publicize their
physical location for Securities sake of
course and of course you wouldn't want
you know those massive data centers
anywhere near a populated city because
they they generate of course you could
imagine lots of lots of noise and lots
of attentions to uh to nefarious people
so they they go somewhere else and you
don't really know about them unless you
actually physically work there yeah
um
so we talk about cloud computing skills
and and you know if you start at the
lower left of this where you
you develop a basic set of skills and
I'm able to you know develop
applications for the cloud or you become
an engineer who's able to work on the
infrastructure of the cloud
you you then have the ability to move
through lots of different
potential career passing
you do uh there is an overlap between
all of them though so you know it's not
that for example let's say we pick the
cloud architect one here on the top left
uh and then you want to be a cloud
developer you're not going to have to
learn 100 new material right because
there is an overlap we all need let's
say storage we all need a network we all
need some machine to compute something
or we call that compute services so
there I would say a good 30 overlap
between all of them you all need that
base
it's the extra 70 that gives value to
what other career path right so if
you're already a developer right
so you know in that um in that poll that
you took there was people with more than
five years experience so if you're
already let's say a developer then of
course you're looking to how do I uh
migrate my skill set to the cloud right
and then you would migrate more to let's
say to a cloud developer role I'm a Java
developer how do I do Java development
in AWS or in Azure or in Google let's
say right so you have to learn that
skill set you have to transition into
that and also then there's you know
different architectures and what about
you know if I want to build a micro
Services architecture in the cloud so
there's a lot of you know aspects to
moving to the cloud some of it you can
leverage from what you already know if
you're completely new that's fine too
right I would recommend going more with
the cloud architect if you're completely
new because that covers all your bases
which reinforces every single other
bullet on this slide right that's the
strongest base the strongest pillar you
can be standing on is the cloud
architect it gives you a global vision
of a vast array of services how they
interconnect to each other right and
then after that it's about going into
the detail of all the other ones and
filling in the gaps great thanks so much
and and you know the the notion of uh
devops of cyber security of data
Administration these are all areas where
if you have that particular banter or
interest you can also
leverage and specialize so some
interesting things about job listings
out there we've looked at Glassdoor and
the average salaries in these industries
from you know people who are
inexperienced uh not to people who are
uh strongly experienced in each of these
job titles so Cloud developers you can
see somewhere in the middle once you've
had several years of experience it's
113k average salary with an upper range
up to 176 or more
than Cloud engineer a bit higher in its
salary range Cloud architect is the one
with the the highest and I'm assuming
when we look at Cloud architect on this
scale we're looking at people who have
developed
a kind of deeper set of skills around
cloud and
um
more experience and that type of thing
would that be fair to say yeah there it
would be they're also the that that role
is more associated with uh being more
client-facing as well so if you're
working for your your company or your
client you're listening to their
business needs and if they're saying
listen we already have an application
running on premise uh we're looking to
save costs improve security uh and go
more Global uh without having to
investing on an on-prem data center
um you know they give you what their
latencies are you know what latencies
would be acceptable and uh then you have
to migrate that to the cloud right so
you have the the business interests at
heart and you have to translate those
business interests to the cloud so you
have to architect many aspects of the
application as well not just porting an
application from one machine to the next
you have to think about uh you know
failovers uh High availability
scalability
um how about backups Disaster Recovery
you know multi-region deployments in
different parts of the world all these
kind of things would be under your
umbrella right on top of that you'd have
to pick the right services to emulate
right what's going on on premise so
that's a quite a big responsibility
right that's kind of the first handoff
from uh the business stakeholders to the
cloud and after that that's where the
cloud engineer would come in right in
the middle here uh where you know
there'd be monitoring uh you know
configuring Performance Tuning looking
at logs if anything goes wrong alerting
the right people automating things and
then you have the developers of course
that have their own environments and you
know doing the development as per
um you know the the business needs so
they're have their own environments that
they're developing on they're deploying
on and you have those
um kind of deployment pipelines there
those integration pipelines that you
have to be aware of too so they all have
their own role but the cloud architect
definitely is is is the one that is the
first one on the line there the front
line in order to start the whole show
yeah
appreciate that
um
that's great advice for people and as
you said
now if there's overlap between the rolls
there's
need to understand the different aspects
of how the cloud works and how as you
said you would migrate from on premises
applications to Cloud deployment or how
you would modify a cloud deployment to
be more robust or or more
functional or scalable
so you need to be able to understand
pretty much all of the different aspects
of
of cloud computing and Cloud management
don't you absolutely yeah you have to
you have to get your bases so you know
what we will we cover in this uh
particular tract here is we go through
the overview of all the services and
then once you get comfortable with
categorizing these services like
networking storage compute serverless
all these kind of things that you'll
learn with me then after we kind of dive
deeper instead of looking at the force
so to speak we go down and look at
individual sections of trees and then
you'll get to know how all of these
Services kind of connect together so you
can build yourself a robust architecture
once you've got that robust architecture
then we start talking about how to
monitor that architecture how to
optimize that architecture and even if
you wanted to develop within that
environment on that architecture we
speak to that as well
yeah
um so
it's important to have kind of the this
well-rounded set of skills because of
the the idea that as you said you might
be
called on to do different aspects you
might want to choose different paths and
being
flexibleness
having that kind of broad base allows
you then to choose where you want to
focus and specialize right
that's correct I just want to mention
also something I keep seeing some
comments here uh here and there which on
which which cloud is better
there is no you know best cloud in
everything across the Spectrum okay but
this is where simply learns program
really shines because uh I mean I I talk
about this more in depth in the course
but a simple learns program here with
Caltech goes through AWS
we go through Azure Microsoft Azure and
we have an elective course I believe as
well for Google Cloud compute or gcp so
you covered the big three okay and
that's that's something that you know I
haven't really seen in other uh programs
kind of differentiates us from the uh
competition now of course you know if
you're more small tech company developer
Centric you like the developer look and
feel of the interfaces Google is really
good for that right as you know there's
a lot of stuff going on in the world
right now with AI machine learning and
Microsoft's really strong with that and
they actually have 80 percent of the
Fortune 500 companies right so they got
a lot of nice features there for the big
companies that are looking for and then
you have you know AWS which has the most
amount of services available right and
the most features available so if you're
looking for any type of service that
does anything that has all the features
then AWS really also is is something to
look at so
keep that in mind but we cover basically
the big two which is at least 50 of the
market right Azure is really stepped up
its game in the last two years and
they've taken about two or three percent
market share and so we're almost you
know we're in the 22 to 25 range between
AWS and Asia right now in certain
categories and the rest again the other
50 the majority of that is Google and
then you have things like you know IBM
um and you have Oracle and then there's
like a hundred other ones there's a
crowded space but we cover we cover
officially we covered the big two which
is right off the bat 50 percent of the
market and I would say
I'm seeing right now a lot of jobs in
Azure uh I'm seeing a lot of jobs in AWS
too but more in Asia right now than I've
seen before and Google yeah it comes up
but for every you know five jobs I see
in Azure I see three in AWS and I see
one for Google right so it'll be up to
you if you want to take those electives
in the course to cover the three
yeah and we'll get into the curriculum
shortly because that's a follow-up to
this question for the audience which is
you know you're all here because you're
interested in cloud computing
potentially as a career choice but what
has stopped you from choosing a program
up to this point
what's been lacking curriculum or is it
the
worry about getting practical experience
is it the learning and teaching style or
is it finding time in your schedule
so I'll leave this open for another 10
seconds you can pick more than one
answer
and uh
present hit the submit button and I will
close this
in three
two
one
and
so the biggest concern Andy is that
people have today is that they're
worried that they wouldn't find a
program that would give them practical
hands-on experience and examples that
they could then show people of what
they've done uh then comprehensive
curriculum is a next most
a worrisome thing for them with the
other two
kind of bringing up the rear so to speak
so
let's talk about this program
again
double jumps from on me
um
so cloud computing boot campus is six
months of online
intensive work but when we say intensive
that's about 10 to 15 hours a week of
time dedication right
yeah that's right we recognize that
everybody has their own lives going on
right whether you're a full-time student
uh full-time worker you have your
families to take care of uh you know
we're not expecting you to do this 40 to
60 hours a week so uh but I think that
you know 10 to 15 hours a week which
includes obviously some weekend work
maybe uh one or two nights a week two
three hours that's that's something that
you you're investing in yourself here
and I guarantee you that if you take
those 10 to 15 hours uh we're talking a
six-figure salary is not uncommon at all
to start off with okay so uh all that
time is well worth it It's a Grind
definitely a grind I get all types of
students in my class I get students like
we saw with over five years experience
even more and I get students that don't
even know what cloud computing is right
we all go on the same Journey the
advantage of course is that I'm here and
so you can ask me either an advanced
question a beginner question we could
take some time to talk about things
outside of the courseware uh to um you
know to address any concerns you have
and it's all about live interaction
which gives it that added value yeah and
that's that's
an important aspect because
it's one thing to watch videos and see
if you can follow along it's like the
difference between buying a cookbook and
taking a live cooking class with an
instructor who can take you through
and
you know actually cook the recipe for
yourself and taste what what the result
is
um very different because you might by
trial and error from The cookbook
Baker perfect souffle ultimately but if
you've done it with the instructor next
to you and you've done it Hands-On
um it'll understand what the final
product is supposed to be like and what
the steps are so it's important both to
have that
live instruction aspect as well as the
ability to do the Hands-On exercises
that's that's what our platform offers
Andy will show that in a little bit but
really it's all delivered online in the
within the same learning management
system makes it kind of
easy and very supportive for the learner
right
absolutely so it's not just you know
recorded videos although we had that and
I and I would expect
if you're in my class uh to view those
videos before attending the class or as
much as you could I I actually always
end off the class with kind of like a
homework saying hey look at these
sections of these videos so that it's
not a complete um completely new to you
when you hear me talking about it that'd
be the best thing however you know
there's also the live training sessions
and not only do I talk about the start
off with some theory of course but I
give you Hands-On demonstrations many of
them where I explain things thoroughly
and uh if you've got questions you can
ask them as I'm going through the
example right and everything is recorded
which is really nice because
um you can then within 24 hours go back
to the recording and actually see those
demonstrations again right because
you're not going to remember of course
who can right every single detail so you
can actually go back and and replay the
live
um recordings as well and there's also
uh time for projects that you'll be
given and uh demonstrations yourself and
if they don't work well that's why I'm
here yeah and and the the platform
includes for those live projects
the sandbox environment for writing the
code but also the
virtual accounts on AWS and Azure to do
the real work with working with
multi-node Cloud kind of configuration
so that you can really build
a working
prototype of what what you're studying
right yeah so the course words in line
with all the resources available uh in
the let's say the AWS console or the
Azure console if you're doing Microsoft
um and it's it's a Sandbox where you can
do no wrong you can do no harm and it
resets itself after eight hours so
there's there's no worries there you're
not going to get charged for anything
it's all part of the course
um and uh you can just it's a playground
where you can experiment and Do no harm
right so I'll be demonstrating this very
shortly but you'll have your own sandbox
you'll have your own AWS and Azure
account where you can mimic all the
actions and do your projects and your
practice exercises perfect yeah
um
the program is designed by Caltech
Center for technology management
education I'll tell tell you a little
bit more about those and them in a
minute but they issue the certificate
um they certify that if you've completed
this program all of the core courses and
then the projects that you have the
skills that that they've designed into
the course and they can put their name
on that
um done maybe 40 Projects
Each of which produces artifacts for
your portfolio including a final
Capstone project we'll talk about that
more in a bit if you're in a field that
requires continuing education units if
your employer requires you to provide
proof of continuing education or if you
work in a field where an agency requires
that
receive up to 30 of those from Caltech
and you receive membership in the online
Caltech ctme Circle where you can
Network a lifetime basis with people
who've taken ctme courses and go to
events that are organized by Caltech
ctme you'll be recognized that an online
convocation where Rick Hefner the
director of the executive director of
the
Caltech ctme or one of his senior
Executives will recognize you by name
and
very important simply learn also
provides a job assist program that I'll
describe later but that extends for six
months after the six-month program so
once you've completed your certificate
you have more help more assistance job
search so
all of that is a pre-rounded package
um
as I mentioned from Caltech ctme we all
know Caltech or I hope we all know
Caltech as one of the top universities
in the world of focusing on graduate
Education and Research
number of people have won Nobel prizes
for for work they did at Caltech and
then an even greater number of people
who won Nobel prizes for work they did
elsewhere
come to Caltech to continue their
research so it's one of the greatest
concentrations of Brilliant Minds in the
world all in one place it's no
coincidence that the
sitcom
Big Bang Theory we wanted to showcase
the quirks of very brilliant people
chose Caltech as its setting and
they formed the center for technology
and management education because
industry kept coming and saying we want
our people to be able to do some of the
things that you folks are doing or at
least understand the techniques you're
using
so Caltech formed this this arm to do
Knowledge and Skills transfer industry
so
having a certificate from Caltech ctmes
is a prestigious
mark on your resume so that's a great
thing to have
um
we're very proud to be associated with
Caltech we're very proud that they chose
us
as their delivery partner for this
program
Andy we talk about Caltech has set very
um
liberal
eligibility requirements
don't have to come in with work
experience or programming background and
you can come in straight out of high
school so
you have talked about how you have
people who come in with a lot of
experience and then people come in with
very little and how does that mix work
how have you seen people succeed with
those different levels yeah so the
people I see succeed are the people that
do their uh background work their
Preparatory work that I uh outlined for
them so
um like I said there's there's work to
do in regards to uh looking at those
videos if you're a complete beginner
right
um to kind of look at those videos uh
it's your duty to then you know
formulate some questions right uh and
ask me those questions they're not clear
if you can't research them yourself you
don't have time to handy I didn't
understand this point yeah you can we
can chat about it I usually show up a
lot you know I don't show up five
minutes before the class I'm usually
there even half an hour before the class
most of the time and so I'm always there
to uh talk and even stay up to 15
minutes out to the class and talk about
things as well so you know I'm there to
guide everybody right so but there it is
a shared learning responsibility right
I'm here let's say for four hours on the
Saturday four hours on a Sunday but when
I go away after of course you know the
responsibility falls on you to follow up
on that right so I've had people like
musicians show up in my class that have
don't know anything about I.T and I've
had people like I said with over 10
years experience so it'll depend on the
kind of motivation Factor you have the
self-motivation factor right and and
also using the resources that
differentiate this program from our
competitors right we don't just have the
live training sessions we have Community
threads forums that are created for each
individual class that I check every week
as well so if you got a question you can
dump it there on a Wednesday and I'll
and I'll go and check that okay I'll
answer you we have a 24 7 help desk
technical assistance that can help you
uh we have mentoring sessions so which
could be me which could be another
instructor it'll depend on availability
but we have a lot of these other
offerings that surround right this uh
kind of live training so
um of course we all start the course at
a very basic level
and yes you might have somebody that say
well this is very basic for me but that
only lasts a few hours right and then we
kind of bring everybody together on the
same journey and yeah we it may take off
and then you may have to do a little
extra work and ask some extra questions
and I might have to help you more but
the point is is that I'm there for that
and the medium to ask those questions
are are available to you
thank you
so
let's talk a little bit about the
program itself in
how it's structured to start with the
induction session which is an online
session that orients you to using the
learning management system where to find
your curriculum where to find your
classes how to enroll in each how to
keep track of your progress
some of the other Basics around
what the
curriculum will look like once you've
completed that
then
you move into AWS Andy is there a reason
why AWS first and then Azure or
that just mostly I would say I would say
it probably was done because they're the
they're the most well-known they're the
the ones that has currently the most
market share uh once you know AWS uh you
know you already have a very strong
foothold in the market uh afterwards
it's just about hey how does how does
Microsoft do the same thing right how
does Azure now what's the difference
between a virtual machine you know in in
AWS versus a virtual machine in Asia or
like how do you create one but you
should have a lot of knowledge to carry
over from AWS to Asia and you'll be able
to compare them and say oh I like better
the way they do it in Asia or I like
better the way they do it in AWS it's
like a car company right there's not
just one car out there so you can
compare many cars out there uh some are
better than others in other aspects
right so you'll be able to make that
that that differentiation now that's the
only reason I think AWS is there before
because there's not really you know much
more AWS material than Asian material
they're pretty much pretty you know half
half uh in this curriculum I give or
take a couple of sessions uh and again
you get more than about fifty percent of
market share after doing that yeah
um you'll be taken through you know the
fundamentals of understanding what cloud
computing is and and what it does but
then you get into in both sorts of the
platforms designing the applications
um looking at the infrastructure how you
would plan out to do an implementation
based on you know the the needs of your
organization
um along the way you can take the master
classes from Caltech instructors uh come
in monthly to talk about
new and different topics within cloud
computing so that adds a lot of flavor
to the of course and then as you
mentioned Andy there's office hours and
project hours that people can take
Advantage right
yes that's correct right so of course
you're going to have questions you're
going to have difficulties you know I
could teach you to ride a bike all day
and you see me ride the bike right and
you can ask me questions about how I'm
riding the bike but once you actually go
on that bike things are not going to go
as planned as we all go right you're
gonna fall and you're gonna get some
bruises and then you might get
frustrated and you say listen I really
need some extra help here uh how do I
you know how do I how do I you know
pedal on the left hand side so to speak
right so when I when I turn so you know
how do I set up a database to connect to
a virtual machine and stuff like that I
I didn't quite get that what are the
parameters that I need so these are the
kind of things we can we can iron out in
those sessions great and then it all
culminates in a Capstone project and
we'll we'll talk in more detail about
that but this is a chance for you to
take all of the skills you've learned
along the way pick a industry aligned
problem and build your own solution to
that so that becomes really the kind of
the the jewel in your
portfolio right if you're a learner
yeah you can showcase something like I
deployed a healthcare application across
uh you know a cluster of machines across
multiple regions something like that
speaks to the fact that okay you
understand architecture you understand
Computing you understand scalability you
know it proves that you've put together
something that could be of value if
hired for that company yeah and the
broad array of tools in both of the
platforms and in other aspects of cloud
computing as well that are not platform
specific and all of the use things are
things you have to
uh kind of use Hands-On in the program
right so you're going to get exercises
labs and projects that cause require
you to use these tools under the
guidance of your instructor
um
uh will you be showing us a little bit
of that
Andy absolutely I could I could you know
just because we're all kind of um
attending a webinar here just to give
you an inkling of something simple
enough that can you know address
everybody because you know we're not all
Experts of course so I can show you how
to create a virtual machine in AWS very
very quickly okay
and we'll just go through this very
briefly before we get to that
demonstration mentioning the Capstone
projects you get to choose one out of
several domains so you have different
industry challenges in different
industry sectors and you get to kind of
choose the one that interests you the
most
solve it with the Hands-On
project that you build
and the example that goes in your
portfolio so in this process
the Learners working with you or another
instructor for several weeks is that
right
yes that's right so what happens is at
the end of each course we cover specific
materials meaning you know we've covered
let's say five services and I identify
which one of those Services correspond
to the work that's needed in your
projects and so I I'll erase that say
hey we just covered let's say
um
you know networking we covered storage
and this is going to be in you know the
project in three weeks from now and so
that puts it on the radar and I say well
you can look at how to incorporate that
in the project right now you can start
looking at that and so that gives you
weeks in advance of time to actually
experiment and get back to me so by the
next course or even if you want to drop
a line in the Forum you can address
those issues instead of waiting all the
way to the end of the cohort right the X
amount of weeks for the course and just
asking me the night before the project
which is of course extremely stressful
for you and I never want that so uh
you'll hear me say things five weeks
before the project hey this point is in
your project let me show you how you
would go about doing this and it's all
recorded so you can always go back and
piece together all those things too
um you know help you complete that
project the point is is so that I can
help you enough that you can do the
project the point is not for me to do
the project for you of course because
then there's no value right but if I can
help you enough to understand how to get
there then I think the job has been
completed
and you as you said you you know you
might look at a health care application
you might look at a consumer application
uh online video kind of analog to a
Netflix or Vimeo or something like that
or you might look at uh
e-commerce you could pick from these
different domains and other projects
based on what interests you and what you
think you would like to have as an
example and if you want to do more than
one
and you have the energy and the time to
do it
you're welcome to to apply that as well
so
um
just before we get to the demo I want to
mention how the
simply learn delivery platform and
community
supports you as the learner we have a
program manager who's assigned to
interact with Caltech to make sure we're
delivering according to their
requirements when you join the program
you're part of a cohort people that it
will go through that program with you on
the same pace so we assign someone to
Shepherd your group through
and of course instructors like Andy who
will take you through each course and
help you understand the material within
the course and hand you off to the
instructor if it's a different one in
the next course
um you have the support of your peers
and your fellow Learners and then you
have the curriculum the resources the
community Forum the help desk uh all of
the pre-recorded materials for
self-study the underlying sandboxed
development environment all of that as
foundational support
and
this is where I invite you Andy to go
ahead and share your
your screen and tell us about
take us through how this learning
environment works sure if you just uh
stop yours I'll be able to uh absolutely
yeah
done okay so let me uh do the
application here
um
whatever reason my
let's see here that's not the one I'm
sorry I'm having a little bit of
technical uh issue here
I wanna advanced
I was able to share an application
before and for whatever reason my the
application is not showing up now
multiple windows
Mozilla Firefox okay let's see if this
actually does it can you actually see my
um it's like a web
yeah
you see your web browser you see the
okay fantastic yeah okay sorry about
that
um okay so let me just move this little
menu to the side here so it's not
interfering with what I'm seeing and uh
open up the uh chat window as well
so what you should all be seeing here is
basically the Caltech cloud computing
uh boot camp
um kind of itinerary all the courses
you'll be taking so like Stuart was
saying this is more of inauguration here
introduction to Caltech cloud computing
bootcamp someone will formally take you
through all the uh steps or the nooks
and crannies of this learning management
system which will referred to as LMS
okay once that's done that's that's
that's just very I think that's just an
hour or two or something like that this
is where I kind of come in with you on
course number two and we take a look at
the AWS kind of the view of the forest
uh kind of a very short uh three uh half
day class on cloud fundamentals looking
at all the services and a little bit of
the details on each one
then the meat and potatoes of it is in
this course here it's kind of five
weekends worth of um so 10 classes of uh
designing applications and architectures
in AWS so this is quite an extensive
course here and afterwards you got the
Azure stuff okay so you can see here you
swap over to Azure and again we cover
many of the same aspects that you did in
AWS but just in the Azure world and then
you end up doing the Capstone project at
the end so this is quite an extensive
curriculum here if I dive into this one
over here this designing applications
and architecture
once I open this up you'll be brought to
the learning management system for this
particular course okay and let me just
pause this over here so we have here a
self learning section which goes through
all of the 10 lessons that I said we
were going to go through okay for this
particular course and you can for
example if you want to know more about
the compute and related features like
virtual machines Lambda all that kind of
stuff then you would have all these kind
of topics for example if we wanted to
take a look at what an ec2 instance is
which is an elastic
compute Cloud it's a machine it's a
virtual machine in the cloud that's all
it is okay this is just branding a
marketing branding here this is what
they call it inside the AWS World ec2
okay and then Azure they'll call it an
Azure virtual machine
so you'll actually see all the slides
they're going through the slides they're
talking about the point so this is not
me that's recorded this this would be
another instructor so you can kind of go
through these on your own time before
the class I'll give you this as homework
this is particularly important for
absolute beginners or beginners in
general okay
because you can formulate some questions
based on what you already don't
understand before showing up okay so me
explaining it me showcasing it after
will reinforce all these points
all of these slides that you see here in
these videos they're all available
through this eBooks download okay and
once you download it it'll be available
in your downloads folder and you can
just open up one of the chapters so for
example chapter three
I actually already uh have it open and
I'll showcase that to you uh later on
okay but they're just PDF files that you
have access to then we have the live
classes
and the live classes are exactly what it
sounds like me and you are together on a
weekend for hours uh and you'll see your
classes show up here of course you don't
see them now
um and I haven't you know if you can
take a look at some of my past classes
you know on certain dates
you could actually see there's been
recordings as well so you can download
the recordings and play them back on an
app that you have to download okay they
don't play back on your computer on your
uh you know without an app being
downloaded first okay proprietary app
um so that's that's where you would go
to actually join up a session that's
upcoming but you will not miss it
because you got tons of reminder emails
that come your way yeah so you get like
two three reminder emails that you can
just click on a link and log in okay but
you could always come here and get the
recordings
then you have these assessments
so after the whole 10 courses are
finished for this AWS class in question
here
um you have to do one of these two
architect tests right so there are 50
questions multiple choice and you only
have to pass one of them you don't have
to pass these two okay so you pick which
one there's not one harder than another
and you have to get a certain percentage
I believe it's 70 but I'll confirm that
in two minutes uh once you do that
you've got one of these three projects
to complete right so for example
how do you configure
and connect a mySQL database instance
with a web server which is going to be
running let's say on a virtual machine
like ec2 and set up a monitoring
solution so there's some very high level
instructions you get to download a PDF
file
but by this time I've already shown it
how you do this right weeks before and
so you know you're going to have lots of
questions I'm going to Showcase you
might need me to show you kind of a
little side demo I'll do that gladly and
you'll be able to do this project on
your own now if there's other other
types of projects now is there one
harder than another sometimes sometimes
you know you need to do a little bit of
more a development now if you're not a
developer that's fine you can stay with
one that doesn't need development we're
just trying to
cover all aspects of experience right
some have many years of experience they
want to do development so we have
projects for those others don't know how
to code right so we have projects for
those kind of Learners as well coding is
not a mandatory requirement it is a nice
thing to know though in the real world
okay so of course I will showcase some
aspects of development and explain them
when necessary but it's not a
prerequisite for the class okay
so if we go back to the self learning
here
and I'm going to pick chapter three
there's these let me just pause this uh
there is these assisted practices okay
and these assisted practices
I do them with you right so I say hey
let me take you by the hand and let me
show you how to actually you know deploy
a virtual machine let's say and with an
application on it of course you can
always take a look at the video version
now the video version although excellent
might not you know uh answer all your
questions because you know the person
doing the demonstration then click on
all the options you said hey what's this
option right that's your opportunity to
ask me Andy what does this option do
right that wasn't covered in the video
or I always wondered what that option
did right and I could answer that for
you live okay so this is a good base but
as you'll see
um I will show you right now how to
actually go ahead uh and do this so we
have a section called practice Labs
which is really cool because it'll allow
you to very easily and you'll all have
access to this is to launch your own
sandbox on launch your own lab
environment in this case
in AWS but of course
let me just uh
refresh of course this would be the same
thing in Azure okay
let me try that again phew
all right so we're just going to launch
the lab and see if that works
oh that's unfortunate okay so what we'll
do is this there there is a username a
password and a link that shows up okay
and you just paste the link in the
browser window and it'll bring you two
and I will show you what it does because
I'll show you my own private things
it'll bring you to an AWS console okay
it'll bring you to this and you would
have to put your username which will be
like oledi student123 which would have
been given to us there you'll have your
password and you'll just log into the
AWS console okay so unfortunately for
whatever reason there's a technical
issue in my account and simpler and it
was working perfectly this morning
but of course demonstrations
always always interesting right
so over here I'll make this a little bit
bigger for you say hello to the AWS
console
so the AWS console is just you know has
hundreds of services right and we get to
learn many of those services in the
course together okay one of those
Services is the elastic compute cloud or
ec2 that's just a fancy marketing name
for a virtual machine a machine like any
other but running in some data center
virtualized on some Rack in some region
of the world okay right now we're in
North Virginia but there are many
regions across the world that I can
choose to launch my virtual machine so
that's pretty impressive right there I
could just as quickly go to London and
launch a virtual machine there okay now
very easily I can just launch an
instance I can say I want to launch a
virtual machine and I want to give it a
name now the whole point of this
demonstration is to launch let's say a
web server and that web server will be
an Apache web server
but I want to deploy my website
okay let me just a web
server
right and I have many different kind of
operating systems Windows Mac Linux
there's different flavors of Linux and
that's all great but for this
demonstration I'm just going to pick the
Amazon Linux flavor which has a lot of
actually
nice features that I'll explain to you
in the class
we can pick our architecture specific
types of machines that have specific
memory
storage CPU power you got really
hundreds of machines you can pick from
I'm just going to pick a very small one
that actually falls under what's called
a free tier so there's no costs to the
learner
and I could even configure a key pair
which allows me to log in remotely I can
configure network settings which I'll
keep as the default here so we'll talk
about networking in great detail
together
and I could even set up firewalls right
to say hey I want to allow a secure SSH
connection maybe the keys that I have
here I have some keys already predefined
I want to SSH into this machine right I
might also want to I'll undo this just
because we don't need to
I'll also want to allow maybe HTTP
traffic or https traffic because it's
going to be a web server deployed in a
website that makes sense right we all
see the HTTP in the URL bar so we want
to allow that traffic in we can set up
storage as well disks right how much
storage do you want so these are things
you don't have to order and wait for
them to come in I could right away say I
want 64 gigs of storage and I get it
right away okay so this is a
pay-as-you-go model you pay for what you
use
now there's an advanced detail section
and it's it's minimized for a good
reason there is a lot of
you know little check boxes and drop
down list box to configure so this is
really an advanced section we go through
most of these in the class and again
this is your opportunity to ask me a
whole bunch of questions here
but this last piece here is a little
Treasure Trove this is where you can
paste a script
and automate what's going to happen
once that machine boots up for the very
first time and so what I've actually
instructed
right is to run a script in the Linux
environment that's going to install an
Apache web server and an Apache web
server is going to deploy a website for
me okay so I'm going to start that
service make sure it's on every time we
reboot so I don't have to go back and
set it all the time
and then I'm going right out a HTML
document right into the proper directory
which is basically is going to be
deployed and say welcome to cloud
computing it's gonna have some nice
colors it's going to be centered right
it's going to have a link to the simply
learn website and I'm just going to
launch this instance and I could launch
if I want you know eight of these web
servers right and I'll pay for all eight
of them for the amount of time that I
use them right but I'm just going to do
one I'm going to launch that instance
now like any virtual machine or any
machine it takes time to boot up okay so
physical virtual of course the virtual
is usually a little bit faster but it
still needs some time to load the
operating system install the Apache
software deploy your website all that
kind of stuff so we got to give it a
little bit of time couple of minutes at
most but while it's doing that we can
see that at least the provisioning of
the physical Hardware on a particular
data center in North Virginia was
probably it was properly acquired the
virtual machine software has been
properly Acquired and installed and all
of a sudden we have the boot up phase
over here so we can go back to our
console for the ec2 service particularly
and we can see here that this is broken
down into very many different sections
which again I exhaustively go through in
the course what we're interested in is
to go look at the instances
and I am going to see here that there is
a web server that I named web server
that's actually up and running right now
but it's still initializing as you can
see and the reason it's still
initializing is because I asked it to
download an Apache web server and deploy
a web application right which is a very
simple kind of a welcome to the cloud
page but still so think of this as you
know you've said reboot my computer but
download some updates right so of course
the computer is up and running but it's
downloading those let's say Windows
updates so you have to wait that's
pretty much what's going on now because
it's executing my script that I said to
automate all right so you could sit here
and kind of refresh the button and wait
but it'll take at least another minute
right while we're looking at this we can
see you know we have a public IP address
that's been assigned or a public DNS
name that we can copy and paste into the
browser once this is been completely
initialized and we'll see the web site
so while we're waiting for another
minute let me go back to the LMS system
and show you some other options we have
this is the community option here
which allows you to go through those
Forum threads again
and I'm just going to pick you know one
random one here uh this is not my course
but if this was you'd see a picture of
me and we wouldn't be able to have a
discussion here uh during the week
outside of classroom hours okay so I
check this at least let's say twice a
week outside of classroom hours just to
make sure that there's no you know
emergencies or anything like that okay
the other thing is let me go back
is we have a kind of a help section here
right so of course you may not be the
first one to ask that question so
there's already some help articles there
but you can also within under under two
minutes actually talk to a live support
person here with with chat with us okay
so that's another thing
that you can do besides that the last is
the certificate section right so I
talked about doing one of those two
tests and I also talked about one of
those three projects right so you have
to do 70 and I was right I wasn't 100
sure but it is 70 that you have to do on
one of those two tests you have three
tries on those tests and then you have
to do one of those projects and submit
that project once you do that and you've
you know
been part of the class right you've
attended the classes and everything you
will unlock your certificate and be able
to put that on your resume there okay
let's refresh this and see if we're up
and running
surprisingly we're still initializing
seems to be uh let me see if we can get
lucky though uh let me actually
paste copy this public DNS name so this
would be like the name of our website or
the public IP address would work too
right of course we would change this to
my company.com right something like that
right but there it is it's already ready
so welcome to cloud computing thank you
for visiting our website click on that
there's just a link to the simply learn
website which would you would then log
into I I would have to log out because
I'm already logged in here okay so
that's very very simply how you can
within minutes deploy a virtual machine
in AWS and it's pretty much the same
thing in Azure with of course different
you know mechanical steps but much
faster to do this on the cloud than
having to order the machines install the
machines configure the machines get
administrators Network Engineers
developers all in line to get this
deployed here so that's pretty much my
demonstration and um Stuart maybe you
can take over here
thank you for that that's the
great walk through
um one of the things you said was it's a
pay-as-you-go model just to be clear
um when you're a learner and you're
using the sandbox platform you're not
being asked to
pay out of your own pocket it's part of
the the
course that's correct yeah yeah so I
don't know what happened there on my
accounts uh somebody got mad at me in
the last three hours
but it'll be the same experience it'll
be the exact same experience as the one
I just showed you my personal account
there would be no difference it's
possible that you went over the um
the the session time limit or something
like that but I don't I I I'm not going
to speculate on that
um so
thank you Andy and I want to point out
that you know Rick Hafner is the
executive director of the
etme and John wetch is the cloud
computing uh segment director these are
the folks who
make sure that we're meeting the Caltech
requirements for delivering the content
of the program to you and we report to
them
um
I'm going to share with you some learner
outcomes kind of briefly but Andy said
you get a broad variety of people coming
into the program
uh information technology and software
certainly but also a banking e-commerce
manufacturing Healthcare pharmaceutical
almost every industry and so you will be
studying alongside
um people who are before their careers
but also people who are in their careers
and in different companies so you might
end up studying alongside somebody who's
working at an Abbott or an emphasis or
Wells Fargo
and that that's kind of an interesting
cultural aspect of the program right
Andy
yes yes that's correct you might you
might find yourself actually working for
one of these companies uh I myself have
taught some of these companies uh
particularly I taught a lot of people at
Deloitte deloitte's a very big company
so but uh yeah you you very well might
find yourself working for one of these
companies uh there are what I meant was
that that if you're in a cohort
there might be other people in the
cohort who are working for one of these
companies yeah I I mean I I get people
from all all all areas so uh yes I've
had I've had you know people from all
these companies actually in my career
since 2008 so it's very possible that
you know you you'll have some in our
courses and that's good for networking
right so it's good to know get to know
each other in the chat uh exchange
um contact information let's hit me on
LinkedIn you find each other uh and uh
that'll build a very good
um kind of business relationship moving
forward you know there's nothing like
learning with somebody else you can you
know Branch off and create your own
learning groups outside of the course
again use those forums and build those
business relationships and it'll
strengthen your your opportunities in
the future for sure yeah and and here's
a couple of the testimonials you'll see
more of these on our website but uh you
know Mario uh on the right uh very happy
with the the new opportunities that
opened up to them Jorge
very happy because the salary doubled so
um these are the kinds of
um opportunities that this kind of
training in the certificate
certification can open up for you and
very pleased to help people with that I
mentioned earlier job assist there's a
chat question about what does that
entail for six months after you earn
your certificate you have access to
the talent Inc
resume rabbit job portal which gives you
some access to exclusive job
opportunities and also gives you a
confidential way of pursuing those uh
this also includes resume review and
rewrite where you'll be working with a
writer who will help you through a
couple of
iterations of your resume to make it
more suitable for automated tracking
systems and AI Bots that will do the
primary screening and then also remain
attractive to
human beings will see it after that
point and then one-on-one interview
service where you get to practice
the different kinds of interviews you're
going to do from phone interviews to
technical interviews and what kind of
questions you'll be asked to cultural
fit interviews and your ability to fit
in with a organization and be a team
player that type of thing so being able
to work with a human being and practice
those the really big Advantage again
this is not a placement program this is
not a job guarantee program but it is a
set of services that you can take
advantage of help you maximize your
job search
the cost of the program is just shy of
10 000 US dollars 9999.
not sure why we we do it that way
instead of just flat ten thousand but
the financing available on an equal
monthly installment basis is 80 a month
and we ask you to hurry because in order
to take advantage of the
bonus
which we'll tell you about in a moment
is uh you need to to be able to sign up
for the next coming cohort and we try to
limit the the size of the cohorts to
about 25 or 30 people so that
there's enough time for people
to interact with the instructor and the
instructors can interact with
individuals on an individualized basis
so
uh based on what we've said so far are
you interested in joining this program
is this open for another
five seconds
or three
two one
and
it's 50 50 split
we know that it's not for everybody
but
for those of you who are interested
share with you the next cohort date
which is
coming up you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net we'll review your
qualifications ask you a few questions
offer you admission if you qualify and
the next classes start on 24 July you
can do the induction session the same
day so
um again we limit the number of folks in
the cohort
and if you reach out to us at ask us at
simplylearn.net they'll be able to share
with you the amount of the discount
offered that's your bonus for being here
today
um
significant discount off of the program
fees so if you are able to sign up for
this cohort
and claim that offer
for those of you who are interested
something that you want to do
right away or is it something that
you're looking a little further down the
road
and we always ask
as we know that if this is something
that's going to change your life and
your career
and put you on a higher path
always worth doing sooner than later
close this in five four three two one
and
about half of you want to get involved
either in July or maybe August September
cohorts uh for those of you looking
further down the road
please email us and we'll keep you in
touch and we'll keep you informed about
future cohorts as well
and answer any other questions you may
have through our learning Consultants
so with that I'm going to go to the Q a
we had a couple of questions that came
in
and Andy
um
you had addressed this before it was a
question about which cloud is better and
you reiterate you know
why different clouds exist in
how people work with them
you're unmute I'm sorry
sorry about that yeah I had addressed it
already just because I had seen the
question in the Q a and uh another
comments but you know there there's
there's different entrepreneurs in this
world just like why do we have so many
car manufacturers or why is there so
many different dishwashers that you can
buy I mean there is no other answer
really than that it's it's it's
basically the entrepreneur Spirit right
uh now of course everyone has an edge
like I said if you're more
developer-centric developer tools uh
small uh companies uh you know a group
of three developers that want to tackle
a huge project but develop have the
developer tools that are more in line
with uh developer Styles then you'll go
more with uh with Google right Google is
very good also with other aspects like
machine learning as well not not just
Azure Azure is more for the you know the
Fortune 500 companies they they really
migrated in in a high percentage toward
Asia or like 80 as I said before that's
a lot for 500 companies are with Asia
they have a good mix of services all the
region availability and costs their
costing scheme is a little bit more
controlled and so for big companies that
are spending millions of dollars on
their cloud and then you need to know
exactly where the spend is right and
they can pinpoint it azure's probably
got the best pricing identification
model uh AWS though they've been there
right since the beginning so 2004 is
really when they started with their
first service so they got a leg up
before everybody else so they have many
more services uh and um although their
pricing scheme might be a little bit
more obscure I have to admit uh they had
the maximum amount of services and
features available so if you don't want
to be missing any Services any features
uh right
um for the vanilla company vanilla sized
company that seems to be the choice
these days
okay we got a couple of questions
related to security one is not us who
says it's not a programmer or techie but
works in
uh uh infraste security governance risk
and compliance
what aspects of cloud would
not us be able to move into and what
kinds of
aspects would be would you want to focus
on
well if you want to focus on we do have
there is a security certificate more for
uh for uh naws for kind of security but
if you want to talk about compliancy uh
governance and all that that aspect is
more done in the CIS Ops or the cloud
operations part of the um of uh of the
AWS world uh and so we cover the
services responsible for that I'll speak
to the AWS side of things because those
are the courses that I teach uh we kind
of dabble in that a little bit but it
that although we mention it quite often
uh that you know if you want to be
compliant the services like HIPAA
compliant let's say
um
uh and there's many other kind of
governance standards there uh we do talk
about that but it's mostly in passing it
we don't concentrate on it I won't say
it's a core tenet of the uh course
material you'll know what services
you'll know where to go to get all the
documentation to prove to your clients
that you have a certain level of
compliancy uh for example AWS artifact
has all those documents uh but it's
definitely not like Hey we're going to
take four hours to talk about it we
don't go into that depth because it's a
very small band it's a narrow band in
the AWS Spectrum
um we have a question from
ravenshop who says the penetration a pen
tester in cyber security
um how does this relate to Cloud well
the cloud the thing is it's the shared
security responsibility model so uh AWS
has um has a shared responsibility to
stop kind of people doing uh kind of
repetitive tasks to attack you right so
you know trying to figure out
um you know kind of iterating through a
whole uh
list of attacks let's say
um
they stopped that at the edge right
there are services that actually protect
you at the edge so you get protected by
big brother so to speak just by being
associated with a cloud provider if you
want to do your own penetration testing
you should advise AWS before right now
usually they'll allow you to do that in
your own account okay but the thing is
if you don't advise them then what could
happen is they could just shut you down
right so because of that shared
responsibility model
um they're protecting you right off the
bat right so if they see somebody some
some weird suspicious activity like
somebody trying to do a penetration test
on and on an ec2 instance let's say
they'll shut that down right away so
always better if you're in that business
to let AWS know before that so that you
don't get shut down okay
um
last couple questions Morgan asked if
someone very new to the I.T world
uh
should choose cloud computing as a place
to enter
this is a good place to start
it's a good place but you should also
know for example what a network is uh
what a subnet is what an IP address is
what a router is what a switch is uh
what a virtual machine is you know these
are the kind of meat and potatoes of the
industry and I would I would appreciate
if you would know that uh before you
know coming into the classroom or else
you're just going to be giving yourself
an extra learning curve it's kind of me
like me saying do I need to know any
math before learning algebra well you're
going to need to know some arithmetic
right so get to know some arithmetic
before and then you'll those Concepts
will come up in the cloud okay
yeah
um and I'll just answer this last one
from Olo which is what's the program fee
do you require Microsoft laptop or does
a Mac work fine
um program fee we covered is the 9999
and it can be financed at 880 a month
um you will be able to claim a discount
if you want to get into this next cohort
and
um
I'm assuming that I
web browsers on either Macintosh or
Microsoft platforms work fine right I
haven't in terms of web browsers I
haven't really
gotten into any issues with those now
so that's either of them should should
work quad that's all the questions we
have and so I'm going to move on to just
the last
um
thank you to our audience and first I
want to thank Andy for being so generous
with his time and with his knowledge
um we really appreciate it
um so thank you Andy thank you everybody
for attending thank you very much
uh the QR code should be able to take
you to our web page I'm going to drop
that into the browser or the chat rather
as well
um along with the email address that you
see there
and
so I'll leave that in the chat for the
next minute or two but you can go to our
webpage see more information about the
program contact us through there and
claim your discount so
we want to thank everybody who's joined
us today taking your time out this
morning to participate in this webinar
we hope we can welcome you into the
Caltech and simply learning community
we look forward to seeing you there so
thank you and that concludes our webinar
and as I said I'll leave the session
open for just another minute so you can
grab the the links we that completes us
for now
goodbye everyone thank you